well new data shows restaurants and deep
blue cities are struggling to bounce
back from the pandemic this while a lot
of eateries and red cities are thriving
let's bring in greg urban he's the owner
of wild greg saloon he's got locations
in minnesota and texas and florida greg
uh
you really say that the state of play in
the restaurant industry right now is
feast or famine and it all comes down to
location location location tell me about
your spots
yeah well it is all about location right
now uh florida you know florida never
really closed and it is just off the
charts booming right now
texas is doing well
but uh minneapolis and uh from what i
hear the other democrat uh cities are
not doing well and we're certainly
seeing that in minneapolis right now
so you've told us that the places where
the covid uh mandates and lockdowns were
the harshest or where restaurants are
now hurting the most the data actually
bears you out take a look at this these
are the locations the cities where the
industry is hurting the most minneapolis
san francisco you got the percentages
there portland seattle
philly new york st louis washington dc
baltimore and chicago
i mean this mirrors what you just told
us
yeah no that that's absolutely true
you know you went through went through
15 months of lockdowns and mandates one
day we were locked down the next day
masks were required the next day
vaccines were required and at the end of
the day people just found it easier to
stay home and a lot of them
unfortunately still are staying home in
the you know the democrat cities like
minneapolis so it's really unfortunate
and and certainly then there's the
backdrop of the crime uh you know people
have to deal with the crime and
the sort to go downtown minneapolis
right now and a lot of people are either
staying in the suburbs or just staying
home unfortunately and and we don't see
that in austin texas we don't see that
in pensacola florida uh
we see in the in the red states people
are still going out and and having fun
spending money
so greg here are the cities that are
booming right now take a look at this
las vegas is topping that list with up
35.7 percent then fort lauderdale miami
austin naples tampa
nashville san antonio scottsdale
phoenix
greg what is the government the biden
administration right now doing to try
and help
restaurants
are they doing anything to help
the cities that haven't caught up yet
no nothing nothing at all i mean
everybody's pretty much on their own
right now
you know we have biden inflation that's
uh through the roof so
certainly our costs continue to go up
and when we're having trouble getting
people to come out to start with it
certainly affects us being able to
raise our prices to cover those costs in
cities like minneapolis so
you know the bars and restaurants right
now are on their own and that's why you
take a walk through minneapolis you see
a lot of places that are closed and
i don't see that changing
anytime soon you know we're hoping the
elections this fall
help and and that's probably our best
shot
there was a 27 billion dollar restaurant
revitalization fund but
after effects look at that showed that
most of the money there about 78 percent
ended up going to big change
big names that already had you know a
lot of financial security leaving the
small owned businesses to crumble um
greg we wish you the best with all your
locations we got to leave it there but
thank you so much for joining us
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now